I'm happy that I have good news for you
we have reached the unanimous approval
of quotas for demersal stocks fishing
for the period 2017 and 2018 in the area
of Agriculture we also discuss African
swine fever spread by wild boars we also
discussed the bird flu flu hp8
we also discuss important topic and that
is a animal welfare during transport and
the establishment of the EU platform on
animal plat animal welfare by the
Commission it is necessary for Member
States to intensify their controls of
transport of animals in order to be in
line with the applicable legislation in
our negotiations we also focus on
antimicrobial resistance it's necessary
to make progress in every and single
member states because resistant party
bacteria do not recognize borders this
is a very crucial topic but that needs
that calls for a coordinated action in
the area of the development of new
antibiotics fast diagnostic tests and
the introduction of detailed plans for
the consumption and use of entra and
antimicrobial substances in member
states for the first time in six years
we have a unanimous agreement on
deep-sea tags and quotas for the next
two years an agreement which will enable
us to better manage deep sea stocks
today we discussed the three main
challenges which we all face first that
data is either not collected or not
properly analyzed by the national
scientific institutes secondly we have
reached many deep-sea stocks so
intensively that they have been at low
levels for a number of years and thirdly
we know that many of these stocks are
fished in artisanal small-scale
fisheries that depend on these fisheries
stay lack alternatives it is also
crucial that the North Sea multi-annual
plan is adopted soon so that we have the
right tools in place to accompany this
development finally I urged all the
ministers to comply with all their
obligations so that they can benefit
from the financial support available to
them under the european maritime and
Fisheries fund